welcome to gamespot news update I'm Tony
Wilson dice has shared more details
about how effects like rain and fog will
change the course of the match in
battlefield one for more on this we go
to Tony with the weather thanks Tony
dynamic weather is new to the
Battlefield franchise and it greatly
affects how you play the game simple
changes like sunlight breaking through
the clouds won't do much but major ships
like thick fog will totally change how
far into the distance you can see heavy
rain won't necessarily affect how far
you can see but it will be very
distracting the downpour can also affect
the mobility of infantry and aircraft
more extreme changes like sand storms
can affect certain maps which limits
vision dampens hearing and makes it
harder for planes to stay in the air
this is a special case but general
weather effects will occur on every map
back to you Tony thanks Tony battlefield
one comes to xbox one ps4 and PC on
october 21st you can also hop into the
public beta on all of those platforms on
august 31st thank you for watching
gamespot news update and for all the
biggest battlefield one news you're
already in the right place